if we treated names the same way certain  people treat pronouns  hey there nice to meet you brian uh  actually it's alan  no it's not  what  your name it's brian it's not alan  i know what my name is  look i can tell you're brian you look  like a brian stop pretending you aren't  a brian but i'm i'm not like fat like  factually that's not mine oh did i did  it hurt your feelings brian  did i hurt your little brian feeling no  i'm just confused what do you even do  i'm just telling the truth everyone else  is afraid to tell you you're brian deal  with it i'm not gonna spare your feeling  i i think there might be genuinely  something wrong with are you having a  stroke  brian  bryan oh crap okay i'm gonna call an  ambulance